From what I read on my mycotoxin report, depending on the type where there are so many foods
you could get them from, it's difficult to avoid them all, but supplements are used to detox
mycotoxins in particular. So mycotoxins are toxins, they're inter substances like heavy metals or
poisons or chemicals. So any of the keylators were so depending on what I may recommend for you,
there's there's keylators that are specifically named for mycotoxins like mycotoll from research
nutritionals, but you know that's not any better of a mycotoxin detoxifier than some of the other
binders and keylators out there, it just has the name Michael in it, so that's how they're
marketed. So any keylator or binder can help pull that out of your body. Yes, there are a lot of
foods that you could get mycotoxins from, but you look at the type of mycotoxins you have,
and if they if it is the type of mycotoxin that you can get from food, you have to kind of weigh out
what are what are the most common ways of getting them? It's just like anything else that I get
poisons from my environment, what are the most common ways that I get those poisons? Well, you know,
they're, you know, from you know, our foods that we eat and from the things that we breathe in
things that we spray on our lawn and think chemicals that we use at our house. So we we make changes
that we can make that we can live with. We can't be obsessive-compulsive about it and we would not
be able to live in this world. So you have to have a balance of what you can do and what you're
willing to do, because I've said this to just what everybody would have gone over your reports. I've
had people that have just like been flammergasted at their at their toxicity report, you know, with
multiple toxicities and cannot believe that this is true, because they meet organic their entire
life and they've just, you know, have lived such a clean existence. Well, remember, your level of
toxicity at any given time is equal to your the degree of toxin exposure, whether you're breathing
them in, which is ubiquitous everywhere, whether you're eating them, which is cross contaminated even
in your organic food, whether you're exposed to on your skin, whether you're, you know, however,
they're getting in your system, your level of your level of toxicity is equal to your level of
exposure minus your ability to detoxify. So many times people have issues with detoxification pathways
and we genetic issues with detoxification pathways so that they're just slow detoxers.
If that's the case, your level of exposure may not even be that high because you're doing so many things
well, but you just don't get rid of what you, what you take in and you're not, you're so your level of
toxicity is hot, relatively high. But it's not just genetic issues, you know, if you damage your
liver over the years, you, you know, right, a lot of alcohol, you, you know, taken medications,
you underwent surgeries with had to be on drugs, probably the number one damage to our liver is,
is medications. I don't take any medications, never prescription medications, but I'm on Tylenol
everyday. Okay, well, I mean, 15,000 people a year, the United States die of Tylenol poisoning
every single year. I would hear about those kind of things. We are exposed to so many poisons,
so many things that damage our liver permanently, that decrease our ability to detoxify.
And then, then we, these things build up in our system and can cause all sorts of issues. So
that's just the simple facts of life. So you have to make that decision where you draw that line
and know that, you know, toxins are probably going to eventually kill us all. So we all have to make
that decision where we're going to draw that line.